-Rachel, it is your turn.
Pull the mic and let's see
what challenge you get.
Yep.
-Yeah, Rachel!
-Rachel!
-No Whammies!
No Wha--
Ooh! Nonsense Karaoke!
Here we go!
-♪ Nonsense Karaoke,
this is Nonsense Karaoke ♪
-Alright, this one's tricky.
You're going to have to sing
a well-known song,
but the lyrics have been
replaced with total nonsense.
-Oh, boy.
-Okay?
-Okay.
-Let's see what song it'll be.
-Oh, okay.
[ Beeping ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aww!
-"It's the Most Wonderful Time
OF the Year"
by Andy Williams!
-Yay!
-We all know that song!
Well, not like this.
Rachel, whenever you're ready,
step up to the mic.
-Over here? Okay.
-And the music will begin.
Rachel Dratch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Band, whenever you're ready.
[ Band playing song ]
♪♪
-♪ Ding, dong, ding, dong ♪
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Ding, dong, ding, dong ♪
-♪ Tap, tap, tap, tap, tap,
tap ♪
-Yeah!
That's a little low.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-How do you nail it?
You nail it all the time!
-Thank you. Thank you.
-You nail it all the time.
Rachel Dratch!